Russia has suffered a number of setbacks
in its war against Ukraine one of the most
glaring its recent big call-up of
more troops a plan which does not
appear to be working Holly Williams is in
Ukraine's capital of Kiev with the latest
good morning Russia's announced that its finished
mobilizing 300 000 reservists to back up its
forces here in Ukraine but there are more and more
signs that Russia's Invasion could be unraveling
Russia's mobilization has caused
anger at home forcing the old and
inexperienced inter-uniform with claims
they're short of even basic equipment
the call up followed weeks of embarrassing
setbacks for Russian forces as Ukraine has
retaken swaths of its territory on Russian State
TV at times the tone seems close to despair
Russia miscalculated its strength and for eight
straight months can't win says this commentator
and perhaps another sign of Russian desperation
is its new tactic targeting the Ukrainian power
grid it's led to blackouts here in Ukraine but
no collapse in morale as Russia's nuclear forces
started annual drills this week President Putin
repeated his government's allegation that Ukraine
could detonate a radioactive device a so-called
dirty bomb some fear Russia's planning a false
flag operation staging an incident and blaming
Ukraine perhaps as a pretext for using a nuclear
weapon I'm Mark guaranteeing you that it's a false
flag operation yet don't know but it would be a
serious serious mistake Ukraine's defense minister
told us Russia's exhausted and trying to force
Ukraine and the West to negotiate but what you're
describing is sort of nuclear or radioactive
blackmail yes this is a black male in a bizarre
speech this week President Putin railed against
the West including gay pride parades and so-called
cancel culture but he also said that it would
make no sense for Russia to use a nuclear weapon
President Biden's response to that was quote if he
has no intention why does he keep on talking
about it Michelle all right Holly thank you